Give your food a face with Edible Disguises.
And then give your face to food by printing
it on a slab of marshmallow.
Because it’s episode 47 of LÜT.
Start the day by cruising over the water on
your Quadrofoil.
The all-electric, eco-friendly personal hydrofoil
has a silent motor, zero emissions and is
unsinkable.
So sink your teeth into cookies that say whatever
you want.
The customizable cookie stamp comes with interchangeable
letters, numbers and symbols.
To slam dunk into coffee made with the world’s
toughest coffee maker.
The CoffeeBoxx is crush-proof, rust-proof
and dust proof and designed to fuel rugged
places like construction sites.
Then construct a Rube Goldberg machine in
your bedroom.
The Chaos Tower is an award-winning kit featuring
602 building pieces including chutes, slides,
funnels, trampolines and a motor-driven chain
that lifts the ball to the top of your epic
creation.
Create fireballs with the PYRO Fireshooter
- a professional tool (not a toy) that allows
someone over the age of 18 to launch fireballs
from an open palm.
It’s designed for magicians and has four
barrels - just make sure you carefully read
and agree to the disclaimer.
Proclaim your love for your pets by having
Susanna Patterson immortalize them in watercolor.
Simply send a snapshot of your dog, cat or
donkey and receive a beautiful one-of-a-kind
portrait.
Digitize your words with the Livescribe smart
pen - that uses an infrared camera to instantly
transfer handwritten notes to your phone or
tablet.
Which really seems out of this world…
Planetary glass set.
Bring the skies in for a safe landing thanks
to furniture made out of airplane parts.
MotoArt sells everything from a fuselage bench
and wing conference tables to a jumbo 747
engine bed.
That honestly could really use a pizza blanket.
For a sweater that ain’ nuttin to blank
wit enter the 36 Chambers - just don’t forget
to protect yo neck.
With this Wu Tang scarf.
Then scarf down some egg flan using a Japanese
egg-spinning device.
Because why not?
Or spin colorful ferrofluid around inside
this bottle using a magnet.
Available in blue or gold it moves around
in different ways depending on magnet placement.
Place your head in your hands after 3D printing
it.
Upload a side and front photograph of your
head and the system will map your features
and 3D print a small, medium or large recreation
of your noggin.
Which is cool - you gotta hand it to them.
Mechanical iron hand it to them.
Charge all your handheld devices with the
ChargeAll - the world’s smallest portable
power outlet.
Just charge the ChargeAll and then bring it
anywhere you need to power your stuff.
It’s like carrying around energy.
If you’re running on empty and ready to
put it in park pull into the CarDok - that
doubles your parking space and secures your
vehicle underground.
But before you roll your socks into skulls
please remember to hug me.
I’m trying!
And as always - thanks for watching!
If you need a crate of loot check out the
Vsauce Holiday Crate from Loot Crate.
With an exclusive Vsauce T-shirt and six mystery
items.
With 100% of the Vsauce proceeds from this
holiday gift box going to benefit Alzheimer’s
research.
Go to lootcrate.com/Vsauce.
Go now!
Go do it now!
Now Go!
Go now.